hello everyone the nord medic here and
you're watching animated biology with
urban in this video let us understand
the clinical picture of breast cancer
now breast cancer is the cancer that
forms in the cells of the breast and
after skin cancer breast cancer is the
most common cancer diagnosed in the
women of united states
now breast cancer can be
in mains as as well as females
but
so far it is way more common in women
than men
now what are the symptoms of breast
cancer now the symptoms of breast cancer
include a painless lump that you can
feel during taking a shower in a moment
of intimacy or while looking at your
breast in the mirror and there can be
also certain skin changes like puckering
or dimpling or certain ulcers on the
skin
most of the times the symptoms of the
breast cancers are painless and trivial
and this leads to a delayed diagnosis in
breast cancer so it is highly
recommended that whenever you feel a
lump
even if it is painless or some trivial
skin change or change in architecture of
the breast you should go and consult a
doctor as soon as possible
now how we diagnose a breast cancer
now first the doctor
takes a patient's history and aims to
look for the risk factors of breast
cancer the risk factors include the age
the prior breast disease and radiation
exposure history
the history of estrogen and
contraceptive exposure the use of
alcohol and obesity alcohol and presence
of obesity and age of menarche and
menopause
and the age of first life birth and
duration of breastfeeding then the
doctor performs a clinical examination
which includes inspection that is
looking at the breast and palpation that
is filling the breast with hand now
inspection that doctor inspects the
breast the skin over the breast the
nipple areola complex that is a
pigmented area around the nipple
the axilla that is underarms and in
palpation the doctor feels for the
temperature and any pain in the breast
which is known as tenderness the doctor
looks at the number and dimension of the
lumps if present the margin and
consistency of the lumps that is whether
the lump is soft hard or firm
and the fixity of the lump to the skin
or the underlying muscles of the
chest
now once clinical examination and
patient history is over the doctor sends
the patient for radiological
investigation now radiological
investigations include an
ultrasonography or usg a mammography
which is a type of x-ray and mri if you
don't know about usd and mammography i
would suggest you to check out the
videos on our channel where we have
explained in detail the concept of usg
and mammography
now
this radiological investigations are
interpreted using a system known as
bi-rads that is breast imaging reporting
and data system now based on this bias
data the doctor again sends you to a
pathological examination
what is that it can be a fine needle
aspiration cytology or known as fnac
which is a cytopathology technique that
means doctors in the operation theater
takes out some
pieces of cells from your
breast lump and examine and examine it
on the microscope to see for cancerous
changes
or it can be a core needle biopsy which
is a histopathology that means the
doctors take out a piece of breast
tissue or the breast lump tissue and
examine that under microscope now these
three investigations help the doctor to
diagnose the breast cancer now sometimes
an immunohistochemistry is also
performed which tells the doctor about
the receptors present on the surface of
the cancer cells of your breast
now based on that they can target the
cancer therapy
and this is the basis of something known
as a targeted breast cancer therapy
now breast cancer treatment includes
different modalities
and depends on the histo histological
type or immunohistochemical type of the
breast cancer the severity of the
disease the patient's profile that means
the age
the race
socioeconomic status and affordability
of the treatment
now
the mainstay of treatment is mostly
surgery
which can include a mastectomy that is
removal of the entire breast or a
lumpectomy that is removal of the lump a
breast conservation surgery or a breast
tonka plastic surgery now apart from
that you can go for radiotherapy
chemotherapy or immunotherapy or even
targeted therapies and hormonal
therapies now which one is suited for
you will be decided by the doctor after
performing all these investigations that
we discussed now
now i hope you have understood this
concept well if you have understood that
please go and check out the instagram
and facebook page of animated biology
with urban to get high quality notes and
flash cards for free the link is in the
description box below also you can
support our channel so that we can
continue to make high quality
educational content for free by
subscribing to us on patreon and you can
also use the super thanks icon to
support our channel which is present on
the bottom right corner of this very
video
and you can use paytm paypal or upi to
pay us
if you wish to connect with urpan of
animated biology with arpan the social
media links are given in the description
box below and for medicine related
content you can follow me the nordmaric
on my youtube channel and you can get in
touch with me through my phone number
insta handle facebook handle and my
email id the links will be again given
in the description box below until then
bye bye see you in the next one